today i just had the time so i decided  i'm going to read some of my hate  comments just pearly things i don't know  her real name it's one of the worst pick  me pick me's i have ever seen all the  videos on her channel are bashing women  and glorifying pig medum i am gonna go  out on a limb and say that she's ugly  her character's ugly and is trying  really hard to stay relevant by making  videos that only resonate with red  pilled men  honestly a pathetic move from a woman to  throw other women under the bus  i know men i have four brothers i have  five brothers thank you i need a big  clown emoji that one that one is only 25  and is already an  inter  inveterate on veteran pick me there is  no chance for her